tu fais pas bêtise d'accord j'étais mon
fils et moi aussi je t'aime maman
quand ton père a disparu les garde-côtes
ont tout fait pour leur trouver je le
sais puisque je leur ai donné un coup de
main si ma mère apprend que je suis
parti en bateau à la recherche de mon
père ça va être game over pour toi j'ai
compris
les gouttes moins bien tu veux demain on
va prendre mon bateau et on va y aller
ça cette maudite ils m'ont personnes
j'arrive papa j'arrive à l'eau tu as des
nouvelles de félix
les partis sur un bateau pour retrouver
son père
je crois qu lice à ferrer quelque chose
ni de la nuit et carnet est ce que vous
croyez en légende qu'est ce qu'il y a un
trésor sur l'île de la nuit éternelle
[Applaudissements]
tomber avec moi hier un passage secret
ça bouge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
morgan qui a le pouvoir de donner à
n'importe qui la jeunesse éternelle
quelque chose me dit que ton père ne
doit pas être là et comment vous savez
ça me i'm a man vous passer le reste de
leur vie à nous attendre
[Musique]
vous pouvez dormir sur vos deux oreilles
madame
[Musique]